hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled deciphering t-cell heterogeneity
in humans through analysis of antigen
specificity i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
fluidem so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as
many questions as you'd like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's speaker dr evan newell
associate professor of vaccine and
infectious disease division at fred
hutchinson cancer research center
for a complete biography of dr newell
please visit the biography tab
located at the top of your screen dr
mule
welcome please begin your presentation
okay thanks so much for this opportunity
to fluid i'm for hosting this webinar um
and for the invitation i saw the other
speakers and it's a real honor to be a
part of this
um so i'm gonna talk about
um deciphering t cell heterogeneity in
humans here
here are my disclosures in particular
i'll talk about how i
co-founded immunoscape which is an
immune profiling company and i'll
mention that later as well
so the things i'm going to talk about
today are just first our
our interests and approaches uh we're
working on a number of different things
um and so i'll also just mention some of
our work recently or
in the past years on infectious disease
and also
even more recently with relevance to
coven 19
and then i'll focus the rest of my talk
on on tracking
t-cell responses in cancer
so in general we're interested in
understanding
of the disease-specific immune response
in humans and
we're challenged by the fact that we
only have access to particular
tissues at certain times and especially
we have access to blood
um and of course within any of these
tissues that we get a hold of
there's a huge range of of cells of
immune cell types
and it's not always clear which are
involved in the disease and what they're
doing
especially in blood you could imagine
that there's all kinds of different
things going on
in our body and so how do we know what
immune cells are actually responding to
the disease of interest
um and so we're definitely trying to
understand what we can learn from blood
versus tissue
um how we can focus on disease relevant
cells
and so our strategy has been to focus on
t cell antigen specificity because by
knowing
uh what the t cells are specific for uh
we can then
um know better that we're looking at the
cells that are relevant for the disease
and these this work the goal of this
work is to
track these cells um in the context of
um immunotherapy trials and studies to
look for
better biomarkers or protectors of
outcomes or things like that
um and so i'm definitely interested in
t cell diversity because uh when we
identify these cells that are specific
for a disease of relevance we want to
understand
uh what their profiles mean and actually
because t cells
have such a huge range of antigen
specificity it means that they also have
a very unique experience as they develop
and then as they
encounter their antigen or not in the um
in the context of
of any disease or or under normal
circumstances
and so t cells can can vary in in many
different categories so they can vary in
terms of whether they've
had antigen experience so they can
display a memory
or a factor or an i.e phenotype they
also vary in their abundance
so if there's an antigen exposure then a
t cell would
would expand and show signs of
proliferation and also be much more
abundant
and then we'd be interested in what t
cells can do in terms of what kind of
functions
they can they can do so what kind of
cytokines
they can express or whether they can
kill
we're also very interested in
trafficking receptors such as
chemokine receptors and integrins that
are indicative or can
drive where t-cells are located um
and and there are a number of these
different markers and then lastly
there's
a whole range of phenotypic markers
associated with
dysfunction or such as exhaustion
markers and senescence markers and
things like that
and so being able to look at cells in a
high dimensional way
um has allowed us to then look at how
all these different categories of
diversity including antigen specificity
relate to one another and so our vision
is to
or my vision is to understand at the
same time what t cells are specific for
by focusing on
um their their t cell receptor antigen
specificity is indicated in this
crystal structure um and then at the
same time understanding what their
phenotypes are
um and we're and i'll show a number of
these umap plots in this
in this talk which are i'm sure
everybody's familiar with
um for this webinar series um
dimensionality reduction
plots for high dimensional data and this
is one that we generated many years ago
from healthy uh pbmc cd8 positive t
cells we've been very interested in sort
of understanding the
range of phenotypes for um t cells and
in this case
um cd8 positive t cells and then i
should mention that our the company that
we spun off immunoscape is
um really focusing on these aspects for
their immune profiling
as well and so the way that we look at
antigen specificity
is to use peptide mhc multimers and in
particular is tetramers
and the concept is that t cell receptor
can only
combine to peptide mhc as t-cells
recognize antigen but this interaction
is very weak
and has fast kinetics and so monomeric
recombinant peptide mhc does not bind
stably to t
cells whereas if you complex it into
these multimers
there's cooperative binding and you can
get very good signal
to noise for staining t cells
based on what they're specific for the
nice thing about this is that you don't
have to
manipulate the cells you can look at
simply what they're specific for
and then in parallel assess what they
look like and what they're doing
and so the way that we apply this
further is to then multiplex
these peptide mhc tetramers and so we
developed this years ago
where a strategy that involves using
multiple
tags on the same antigen specificity of
a multimer
and then t cells that bind those tags
specifically will then be stained with a
unique combination
of tags and this works with both
fluorescence and
heavy metal and it's particularly
convenient for mass cytometry because in
this case
if we dedicate 10 heavy metals to
peptide mhc tetramers
it means that we can stain up to 120
different
t-cell antigen specificities at the same
time
and then we have 30 or more channels
remaining
to profile the antigen specific cells
that we detect with any of those
codes and so what we do in the lab is
then get
single pbmc or tissue samples
and then we stain them with these
multiplex libraries of tetramers that we
create
um and then at the same time we stain
them with
antibodies to profile the cells we run
them on the cytoph
and then we'll at the same time get this
deep phenotypic profile of cells
as well as um hits for any of the
tetramers that we've included in the
multiplex
tetramer staining library and just to
show an example of what this can look
like this is a healthy donor um
where it's at the top here we have a
umat plot of just cd8 t
cells with some example markers to give
you some orientation
of what they of what the the different
populations represent
and with our panel we can discriminate a
number of different
cd8 subsets and then on the bottom here
is overlay of the red dots for each of
these antigen specificities and so
what's cool is that
for this healthy donor here we can see
that they have t
cells specific for a number of different
epitopes derived from
these various viruses so adenovirus
epstein-barr virus flu
and then herpes simplex virus and then
we can see
the phenotypes of those cells and based
on those phenotypes we can have some
understanding of what that person's
immune response is doing
um for these for these different viruses
and it also shows that
different epitopes can have different
involvement
in phi t cells and so this is really
what we're trying to take advantage of
when we then go look at
patient samples and try to understand
what's happening
within it with a t cell response and the
nice thing is we always can include
these control epitopes to get some sense
of what
t cells are doing that are unrelated to
the disease so specific for other things
like these
these common viral infections i should
mention also that we're
it's quite nicely synergistic to use
this approach with a multi-omics
single cell sequencing methods that
we're doing more and more of i won't
talk about that much today
but we can use mass cytometry as part of
a screen to identify cell populations
and things that then we want to zoom in
further with single cell sequencing
um so this is just a quick example of a
paper we published
last year studying dengue
acute dengue infection uh for multiple
cohorts in singapore and what was nice
to hear about our approach is that we're
able to
first look at broadly profiling what
happens to lymphocytes in general
over the course of of dengue infection
and we noted of course that in acute
time points there's a massive
activation of many different lymphocyte
subsets
including t cells and k cells mate cells
gamma delta cells b
cells and with this sort of broad
profiling
with mass cytometry we can investigate
the characteristics of all those
different activated cell populations
and that's quantified here but then at
the later time points a lot of this
activation is lost and so it's difficult
to know
what to look at in those samples that
would be related to
um having dengue infection and so for
that we're using the
um the multiplex tetramer approach that
i mentioned
so screening for a large number of
previously
identified dengue epitopes and then we
can identify we were able to identify
dengue specific t cells at all these
different time points and here on the
top right
is an example of how we're able to then
track the profiles of these cells over
time
um and there's a number of different
things we commented about this in the
paper
but interestingly there's really two
major outcomes in terms of the
phenotypes
of dengue specific cells one that have
kind of a memory or stem cell memory
phenotype
and then another that has this more
terminally differentiated effector
phenotype and remarkably that an
including marker like c57 which is
typically a senescence marker
but then we show that those cells are
also long lived and were maintained
even out to a year or more
post-infection so that's kind of a sense
of the types of things that we can do
and especially good for studying acute
viral infection
and so we're involved in various ways in
a number of different
covid19 related projects and so this is
just a real snippet
of data that we've collected very
recently
we're not super fast on this but we're
showing in this case
um some sars kobe 2 specific cells that
we detected
with an h of a b7 tetramer and you can
see the phenotypes here
as compared to some cmv specific cells
that we detected in that same
uh participant sample and this was a big
effort you know to get
going with all of this so the names here
are are also very important and
i'll um thank them at the end as well
so um now i'm just going to move on to
the the main topic that i wanted to talk
about today
uh and that is tracking cancer-specific
immune responses
and you know there's a lot to talk about
so much going on
in cancer immunology but if you think
about this cancer immunity cycle
whereby you know t cell responses would
be primed in lymph nodes
circulate through the blood into the
tumor
and then respond to the tumor what we
have access to
to study these t cell responses are the
blood
and the tumor tissue and so we want to
know what are the tumor-specific cells
doing in each of these
tissues and can we identify them so
first focusing on the tumor infiltrating
cells
um this is a paper that we published
recently we've done
other other studies in mice as well but
this one i'll highlight
which is what's done by yannick simoni
in the lab and in collaboration with
many
others especially clinicians in
singapore
and what we did was to get a hold of
tumor infiltrating t
cells and use our approach to screen for
new antigen specific t
cells so screening for t cells specific
for mutations
uh in those tumors for which we had
exome sequences
and then at the same time we also looked
for t cells
specific for these various unrelated
antigen specificities that i mentioned
such as ebv flu and cmv and what was
striking is that even though we could
identify cases of tumor-specific cells
this was harder because it's screening
so many different epitopes
but what was easier to to identify were
a number of examples
of t cells specific for these unrelated
antigens
derived from evd cmd or flu
and then from this we were able to then
ask okay what's different about these t
cells that are bystanders so they're
specific
for something unrelated to cancer and
therefore
we think much less likely to be actually
tumor specific
um and what we noticed then was in
addition to their being
quite heterogeneous in their profiles
and overlapping
often times with phenotypes that we
would expect for tumor infiltrating
cells for instance they have
pd-1 and tinted and other markers
associated
with exhaustion we noticed that they
were
almost completely lacking cd39
expression
and then based on that we've
hypothesized that cd39
could be a good marker to delineate
these bystander cells from
bonafide tumor-specific cells and then
looking back at all the samples that we
analyzed on the bottom right here um we
notice an amazing heterogeneity and the
frequencies of
tumor infiltrating cv8 that express cd39
this implies that some people have
very very few tumor-specific cells
as a fraction of their total cd8 while
others have a much higher fraction
and so we're continuing to work with
this hypothesis and
uh we'll see whether it holds up but in
the meantime
it's a it's an opportunity then to look
at uh
what do um how can we distinguish
uh these unrelated antigen specific
cells from uh tumor-specific ones and so
there's a number of different things
that we're doing to follow up on this
but the one that i was going to mention
today is looking at
what about cd4 t cells and this is just
to say that
within the panels that we've run we can
also identify
cd4 t cells we can just distinguish
on t reg cells by fox t3 expression
and then this plot just shows that
actually for the tumor types in this
case lung and colorectal for which we
have
a pretty large number of samples uh
there are
there's abundant cd4 infiltrating t
cells
and then amongst those there's actually
quite high frequencies of
non-t reg cd4 t cell so of course
there's a lot
of work done into studying roles of t
reg cells and suppressing the tumor
microenvironment
but what's there as well are abundant
non-t-reg
cd4-t cells and here's an example
of a umap plot for cd4-t cells
in one colorectal cancer patients tumor
and you can see that um there's a
section of this umap plot that
delineates t-regs
um by fox d3 and cd25 expression
and then when you look at cd 39 which
was our interest based on the work on
cd8 you can see that while t-regs
express high levels of cd39 this is
known even in
the periphery t-regs are mostly
expressing cd39
you can also note a large heterogeneity
in cells
that are non-t-reg in terms of that have
some that have c39 and some that don't
um and then you know varying degrees of
other marker expression
um and these are just some examples and
so
so like what we saw in in cv-8
for cd4s we also similarly see
a quite a big range of non-t-reg
expression of cd39 and so you can see
that t-regs
typically express abundance e39 but
these non-t
regs have a larger heterogeneity and c39
expression
um and that goes along with similar uh
you know
diversity and expression of the other
markers
um and so the other interesting thing
that we note
from these data is that there's actually
a strong correlation
in the frequencies of cd39 expression
between non-t-reg cd4 t cells
and and cd8 t cells so this implies that
the frequencies of tumor reactive cells
are sort of coordinated
between the cd4 and cv8 response and
this fits with what you might think in
terms of
how t cell responses are come together
for both the helper and cytotoxic arms
and so we're similarly hypothesizing
that
the lack of cd39 expression on tumor
infiltrating non-t-reg
cd4 positive t cells could be a marker
of their
not getting chronic antigen stimulation
i should have mentioned that ce39
had been reported and is known to be
induced upon chronic t cell receptor
antigen stimulation
and so these cells either have not yet
seen antigen or are not getting antigen
in the tumor because
um they could be bystander cells
infiltrating those
those tumors um and so what ayanik and
chamin in the lab also did was then to
try to look for unrelated antigen
specific cells and tumor infiltrating
t and tumor infiltrates um and work with
tetramers is tricky because the
frequencies are
very low um so instead we started using
these this
antigen or antigen induction
or aim assay sorry forgetting the
acronym for this but essentially what
you do is you stimulate with peptide
pools and look for induction of
a combination of cd69 and cb40 ligand
and that's a representation of of
epitope reactivity
and then what you can do then is we note
that we can detect
cmv specific cells here in this
particular example
from both pvmcs and tumor infiltrates
and then across a number of different
patients we can actually see
quite abundant detection of cmv
specific cells in tumor infiltrates
which
then shows like cd8s that there are
these
t cells that are infiltrating tumors and
that are not necessarily specific
for the tumor but specific for this
chronic viral infection
um and then in this case we were also
able to look at the expression
uh prior to um so we stained with cd39
prior to the stimulation and then for
these cells that were cmv specific that
went on to induce
cd40 ligand they were actually lacking
um in in c39 prior to that
that antigen stimulation so some again
similar
which is similarly in line with what we
saw for cd8s
that these unrelated antigen-specific
cells don't do not appear to be
expressing cd39 when infiltrating tumors
um and so the the gist of this part is
to say that
we think that you know tumors are
inflamed tissues
and then t cells in the periphery
follow inflammatory cues and come into
tumors
and this is probably done irrespective
of t cell receptor signal
and then once they get into those tumors
they can diversify
and express all these different markers
that we talked about
and then for the ones that are actually
tumor specific
we think they can go on and to induce
cd39 expression
and that's one of parts of the reason
that distinguishes them
and so it remains to be determined all
the other functional differences and
that's why
we're doing some other studies to look
deeper at how these different
tumor-specific versus bystander cells
compare
so then the other thing that we're also
interested in of course are um
what have what's happening in the blood
and how can we determine what the
tumor-specific cells look like there
to understand uh what we can learn from
the blood when we don't always have
access to tissue so i'm just going to
mention this study that was done
actually primarily
with a collaboration between immunoscape
and genentech
and led by michael failings as well as
mahasyadev
at genentech where we screen where they
screen for
tumor-specific neoantigen specific cells
from lung cancer patients undergoing
anti-pdl-1
treatment and then able to detect
a large number of hits for low-frequency
new antigen-specific t-cells
and then look for correlations between
the phenotypes of those cells
and the degree to which they respond to
the treatment
and so what's interesting in this case
is that there was an enrichment
for neoantigen-specific t-cells that
display
a more terminally differentiated
effector phenotype
in the responders as compared to the
non-responders and we think
maybe that implies that there's a more
active antigen
exposure um happening for those new
antigens
specific t cells as compared to the
others that are showing a more memory
phenotype
and you can look closer at the details
in that paper
um i also wanted to mention just a
another study that's being led by
nandita kumar who's a grad student in
the lab
and working with colleagues still in
singapore so this is with uh
dr ahmed jane there who had collected a
really nice cohort of
untreated nasopharyngeal carcinoma
patients
and here again we're applying our
approach to studying ebv specific t
cells in the context of this ebv driven
cancer so
an easier way to try to look for tumor
specific cells
is to then study um virally driven
cancers
and so for ebv we often detect
uvv-specific cells in pvmcs
and the question is oh how are they
gonna are they still there and people
that have npc
and how do their phenotypes differ um in
cancer patients versus healthy donors
um and this is just to say that anita
was able to detect
abv specific cells in many of the
patients and
all of the 10 shown here and then we're
able to
similarly profile uh what those ebv
specific cells look like
um and she's noted that um they do
express
a more exhausted phenotype so elevated
expression of tidget pd1
klr d1 and 2b4 as compared to both cva t
cells and then she's also especially
intrigued by
some of the patients that show an
especially
terminally exhausted phenotype which
includes high expression of cd39
um as well as cd103 and then sort of
an enrichment um in this particular
region of this umap plot here
so this is something that we're quite
excited about in following up
and so in conclusion i just wanted to
show um
how our approach works both for um for
for looking in the tumor where we're
seeing
high prevalence of cancer unrelated
antigen specific cells
for both cd4s and cd8s um as well as
you know diverse phenotypes of
tumor-specific cells in the blood
um that appear to have some utility as
biomarkers for clinical outcome
and status and that's something also
that we're working on in the context of
npc
and so yeah so and that's all i was
going to talk about today
so overall um just talking broad
applicability for simultaneous analysis
of t
cell antigen specificity and detailed
cellular phenotypes
trying to gain signal by looking at
relevant cells in both blood and tissue
and then our work in cancer tumor
infiltrating cells
has really been focused on understanding
what's going on with these cancer
unrelated antigen specific t
cells that appear to be quite abundant
in many tumors for both cd4s
and cd8s um and then i highlighted also
some coordination between those two
t-cell types
and so we think that the real and then
for the blood work even though
what i showed is still a little early on
we think that the real power for
tracking
antigen-specific cells will be in the
blood where
we'll have easier access to samples
and once we learn how to interpret these
phenotypes and identify the tumor
reactive cells or other
antigen specific cells that are relevant
for disease we i think we have a lot to
learn
about what these profiles can tell us
and with that i would like to thank
the many people that contributed to this
work in particular
the folks in the lab here at fred hutch
listed here
who've contributed to various ways and i
tried to mention people
throughout in particular yannick simoni
and xiamin lee who worked on the
tumor work and then nadira kumar who was
leading this npc
project and then a number of other
things that i showed were published a
lot of contributors there
but for the cancer work especially uh
folks in
in singapore um jane i mentioned and
then there's a number of other
folks involved in helping us work with
the samples that i talked about in
colorectal and lung cancer and then for
the very short snippet about uh coven 19
this has been a group effort with julie
mcelrath and her team
as well as david cole at uw medicine
and then there's some additional
clinical contributors to the samples
that we worked with and then of course i
mentioned the work with uh
genentech led by mahashyadev and michael
failings
and then of course other folks at
immunoscape
and then just lastly here's a photo of
the
folks in the lab and it's been it's been
great working with them
here in seattle and thanks very much for
your time and this opportunity
and thank you dr new all for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please
do so by asking clicking on that button
so let's get started we have quite a few
questions already coming in dr newell
why the peptides are why are the
peptides attached to metals
so i mean we're using mass cytometry so
we attach actually we attach
the peptides to the to the mhc so we
load the peptides into mhc
and then those peptides are um
those peptide mhcs are metal tagged and
um
and then uh that's how we can detect the
the signal from the staining by the mass
cytometer
so the tetramers themselves are metal
tagged and then we use
combinations of different metals for
those detections
and dr neil what is the lowest frequency
of
tetramer positive cells do you feel
confident of
detecting with the cyclops
yeah this is a this is a really
important question um and yeah we work
really hard to try to improve this all
the time i think the bottom line is is
about the number of cells that you have
so with a larger number of cells then
you can run
more cells on the cytoph and then be
able to detect
um a more rare cell populations um
so i think typically let's say if you
have
you run a few million cells in this or
you start with a few million cells
then we could be able to detect
something about 0.01 percent of
cd8 t cells and this is a the typical
limit of detection for um for tetramer
staining in general so cytoplasm is
quite similar
we're also doing um magnetic enrichment
strategies to further improve this and
we've
included that in some of our papers as
well when we have larger samples we can
go
even
thank lower dr newell and i also want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
coming in and hello to that little
gentleman behind you
just perfect timing yeah he wants he
wants to be a scientist with you
what is the function what is the
function
of cd39 expressed by t cells
yeah i mean this is something i'm also
curious about i mean i think we
definitely are
in this case we're really just using it
as a marker i mean we had it on there
we've included in our panels because
it's it's known to be expressed by
t-regs and then had been
also shown to be expressed by these
exhausted or
you know chronically stimulated t cells
and i think it's
so cd39 is a extracellular atpase that
degree
degrades atp and then with cd73
produces adenosine which has this
negative
feedback for immune suppression in
general so
i think and so cd39 is being targeted um
as for immunotherapy to try to reverse
that
production of adenosine and so i presume
that it's some kind of
feedback mechanism that that t-cells
have where they produce
um cd39 to um to
to limit themselves or possibly um
it could be that atp becomes toxic in
these environments and by having cd39
they're preventing that toxicity so i
think this is an open question yeah
yes thank you and what about the
frequency of cd 39
on cd four plus cells in the
our positive cells in the peripheral
blood of these patients
and or in normals yeah i know
better um offhand for cd8s um but in and
i think cd4s so with cd4s you would of
course need to look at
non-t reg cells so the t reg cells are
going to express a lot of cd39 when you
look within the non-t
reg cells in the blood i believe the
frequencies are quite low for cd8s it's
all
it's it's generally very very low
frequencies of cd39 on cda positive t
cells
um but cd39 is expressed by activated
cells so
um like for instance the the ones i
showed during acute dengue infection
at that early acute time points we do
see cd39 expressed by some of the cells
there
um on cd8s um especially and i believe
um conventional cd4s as well
so i think it's a good marker for for
for something that's really
acutely going on um or having
some some t cell receptor stimulation
in the in the recent past and so that's
why i don't think you see
very much in in healthy donor blood
samples but you do see this
um in the context of an ongoing response
thank you dr new hall and we have a time
for a couple more questions
is cd 39 only um
upregulated within the tmp so that you
would not see these in the periphery
yeah that's yeah i think that was a
similar question as before so yeah i
think um
we see a lot um i mean depending on the
on the patient's tumor
um so you know i mentioned some patients
have really high frequencies of t cells
expressing cd39 while others are
much lower but in the blood for those
patients
and for healthy donors the frequencies
are much much lower
thank you and we have time for one more
question um
this next question does cd39 expression
correlate in effector's um cytokine
expression or cytokine is that private
um does it correlate with cytokine
um for expression so um i think
we so i think if you look at if you take
for instance if you take um
ce39 positive versus negative cells um
and then stimulate them well for one if
you look without stimulation the cd39
positive cells
you know appear to have a more activated
phenotype so they are
higher for ki-67 i'm not exactly sure
whether their baseline levels of
cytokine mrna would be a little bit
higher
we have to check that but then after
stimulation because
they are and they also definitely have a
more exhausted
gene expression signature and so
consistent with that when you stimulate
the cells
um after sorting them the c39 positive
ones
tend to make less cytokines and
especially less il2
um so they're a little bit dysfunctional
as an exhausted cell should be
but of course you know exhausted cells
are not completely dysfunctional
um and so i think that the they kind of
are
are showing signs of being chronically
stimulated and that goes along with this
inability to respond
as well as um expression of all these
markers
so yeah okay thanks so much
[Music]
you know thank you thank you very much
for your time today and for your
important research
i also want to thank bluedine for
sponsoring today's event and i want to
encourage the audience members to check
out other presentations today and
explore the food on
virtual environment where the booths are
located check it out
so before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and the webcast can be viewed on demand
starting today through july of 2021.
until next time have a great day bye-bye
okay bye-bye thank you